welcome to this video I'm playing one
trick pony one trick pony from opponent
right yes well let's let's play caller
opening i recently tried that and so I
know it's not one of the mainstream
openings but it can lead to interesting
play especially a firm white place like
I'm just I'm just doing the B 3 and B
should be tuned this can in fact be
quite an aggressive setup let's see yeah
well do you play Knight d2 or C form
yeah maybe see phone this is probably
more aggressive c4 and possibly Knight
c3 yeah this is a hanging porn formation
and itself usually quite active way to
play an interesting does you really want
to play f5 that's some hard to believe
actually
oh yeah what's um it's possible
I mean if it just takes on c3 then I'm
not sure what 94 was okay was all about
I just lost some time 94 taking on c3
but okay Black is not not in terrible
shape he can just play let's ab6 in this
position okay yeah still does thus be
six but I have to aggressively posted
bishops towards the King side it's as
always always Wow
and what I wanted to say there's always
some aggressive possibilities link to
that yeah well I can just take it with
both its opponent then the night
not quite sure what's better a term
yeah i'm a bit i'm a bit tough at a loss
what what the point of all this is ok
well i can just play Knight f3
and then I can go see 5 and d5 or D
Pfeiffer default immediately but let's
let's go see if I first I still have d 5
because 25 does bishop h7 maybe Bishop
g4 but i have d 60 okay i can play these
things breaking the diagonal to h2 let's
see maybe p 1 yeah many good moves I'm a
could have taken on c5 I actually
actually overlooked that hmm ok well
let's be cautious
you could have taken on c5 played this
um attached too quickly ok so let's see
maybe are there many interesting rules
rugby higher before
if it takes on f3 I'm taking on age five
yeah d6d six is hanging
hmm yeah many many good many good ideas
or interesting ideas I want to get get
rid of the spin
mmm yeah 95 maybe the rock on b5 is a
bit loose this is the only thing that
concerns me those pieces are not
protected but I'm playing with them
immediate threats anthem I hope that
there is no real way to make use of that
yeah this is one of those moves that may
be may be tricky c3 is also hanging hmm
ah hey I am lc3 especially as a problem
and if Bishop takes be 5 mm okay need to
need to move
I think it just takes here and g5 is
unfortunately hanging I mean I'm
volatile evening mmm take here
YUM Roxy 39 f 8 and the squinty form
now the bishop is hanging and denied is
saying everything saying
mm maybe everything's fine yet i don't
really i cannot calculate this that's
what what what should he do I mean these
seven Hanks yeah I think this is good
for me again but he can take d6 maybe
you know but I can just take deform or
not deform look f1 King everyone Quincy
one check kingi to Bishop b5 I can do to
have three i don't i don't really get it
check
check
unique II can play that it's not this is
not what I'm saying but then I don't
think it's particularly great not a
check go here check to protect with
Queen deform check check things covered
I hope check no no I am dead it takes a
special talent to to run into this kind
of nonsense again checkmate yeah one
trick pony the only thing came no no
comment check Oh Jim
yeah my white is winning I want just
check the way I play it I can I could
just go here I mean what what what's the
big deal check check and and over I mean
22 points for nothing ah but I just ran
into ran into the self-made yeah and
their problem probably am I could have
one much easier I mean e5 was completely
ridiculous okay well this is up to this
point I'm pretty pretty sure that this
is this is ok and should just win you
can take c5 p.m. not the end of the
world still good probably yeah yeah I
every member plus for him according to
comp queen d three yeah well
everything's it's good but naci 5pm this
is this is really a loose move and yeah
this is a bad move 95 is just bad
I mean I'm a pawn up with the six bone
and I haven't no evolving the active
position the queen is especially bad
this move in fact is very strong
yeah this is completely over actually
Queen group g six wins Fickell's jakis
and black resigns h7 is exploding yeah
there were many ways to win it but I
really made a self-made problem out of
this and managed to lose ah thanks for
watching